twitter s'est attiré les foudres de
donald trump pour avoir mis des
avertissements sur certains de ces
messages le pdg de facebook et de son
côté critiqué pour son refus d'avoir
dénoncé un message du président qui a
écrit quand les pillages commencent les
tirs parts
mark zuckerberg a tenté d'expliquer la
décision à ses employés lors d'une
rencontre virtuelle mais plusieurs ont
refusé de travailler avant de critiquer
la politique de facebook sur twitter
notre invité pour en parler ce soir
nadia seraiocco doctorante chargé de
cours à l'école des médias de l'uqam
chroniqueuse à moteur de recherche sur
ici première nadia bonsoir bonsoir à
tous et est à signaler donc des messages
du président comme étant non factuels
notamment aux incitations à la violence
facebook ne signale rien et d'y protéger
la liberté d'expression
peut-être nous expliquer d'abord la
position de twitter dans cela merci
twitter a déjà été critiqué pour son
laxisme par rapport par exemple des
messages racisme et l'antisémitisme qui
avaient cours sur le réseau entre autres
en europe et on sait que il avait
tendance à ceux de ben on laisse les
gens s'autoréguler mais dernièrement ils
ont commencé justement vouloir appliquer
un petit peu plus aux dérégulations et
ça a donné quelque chose je dirais d'un
peu plus musclée que ce que facebook
appelée qu'habituellement
parce que fait facebook il faut savoir
raison ils ont nommé des tierces parties
alors des agences de presse etc qui font
la vérification des nouvelles mais pour
ce faire il faut que vous comme usage
rien vous signaliez cette nouvelle là où
cette publication là et ensuite facebook
voilà révisé ils ont même aussi des
modérateurs
ce que pas de voir à ce que les contenus
violents ou à caractère sexuel soit
retirée et la twitter prend un moyen je
dirais un peu plus direct en temps et
quand une publication contrevient à ce
que nous considérons comme acceptable on
voit le noter immédiatement et peint
évidemment que donald trump étant
toujours sur la plateforme il ya
lancement de déclaration le parfois les
gens s'amusent à les débusquer tous les
mensonges possible là où les
approximations dans ses déclarations
c'est clair qu'il allait y passer
éventuellement parce que évidemment il
rejoint un énorme
il est donc tout autant se sentir
responsable je comprends ça a pris quand
même plusieurs années ou et eu à
intervenir comme ça là tout était le
fait mais facebook ne peut le faire et
les la position de facebook dauphin mais
la position de facebook dans ça c'est
qu'ils ont ils ont la même position
qu'en 2016 malgré qu'ils aient mis de
l'avant des mesures pour s'assurer
justement lors de la validité des choses
qui circulent sur leurs réseaux leurs
positions c'est nous n'avons pas à
censurer la liberté d'expression si
quelqu'un exprime quelque chose qu'ils
croient être vrai et ça ça a été les
mots souvent autant de marques figurent
bank de chez nissan bird la sas à sabres
à droite je dirais on ne veut pas les
empêcher de le faire les addictions
autant publicité gerald que dans les
messages que vous publiez
et là en vue des prochaines élections on
sait que les réseaux sociaux se sont
fait demander à un peu partout de
restreindre un petit peu ce qui est
justement le redon d'aller un peu dans
son voeu policiers le temps et les
déclarations qui sont fausses
mais facebook a maintenu ce et certains
vont même jusqu'à dire que quand run
parfait son son ordre là en vertu
hauteur dans le fond tout ça c'était de
l'amour littéralement voilier à mark
zuckerberg qui lui alors peut se
permettre de dire écoutez moi je ne vais
pas commencer à dire ce que dit le
président américain c'est pas à moi de
faire ce saut c'est la liberté
d'expression et je les applique de la
même façon partout l'on pourrait poser
des questions rendu leur impose une
question et nous la ligne 8 elle est où
la ligne c'est ça dans le fond qui
défilent que la ligne de ce qui est vrai
de ce qui est pas vrai de ce qui doit
être dit de ce qui ne doit pas être dit
de ce qui s'appelle de la liberté
d'expression est pas de la liberté
d'expression faut dire que ne sont pas
des médias proprement parler il y a des
modérateurs mais c'est pas du
journalisme et qu'ils font
non ce n'est pas du journalisme qui le
font moins je vous rappellerai que
peut-être deux ans oui c'est
effectivement printemps 2018 jeff jarvis
dans une conférence certaines wright
scott qui parle justement de ces
questions de droits humains nouvelles
technologies georges vi c'est un
professeur ou craig newman journalism
secours
les très connus en pour plusieurs
ouvrages qui l'a fait justement sur sur
le journaliste n'a adopté l'expression
il était là tout récemment très
sollicités pour parler de cette question
là parce que ça intéresse beaucoup
technologies et il nous disait pendant
que facebook continue à engager sur le
terrain des modérateurs qui ne vous
trompez pas non pas un travail d'éditeur
ils ne vont pas validé ces modérateurs
loi
ce sont des tirs ce parti des compagnies
comme qu'aucun agent qui jusqu'à tout
récemment gérer ça ils sont presque 20
et mais elle est des fois plus insolent
et période du dre de l'année et il lui
disait mais pendant ce temps là les
journalistes alors dans le pool de gens
qui travaillent dans l'immédiat qui sont
tout près de 200000 aux etats-unis le
nombre de ces gens là qui font de
l'éditorial qui révise les nouvelles et
ces terres sont à peu près de 30 mais
faites-le vous imaginez bien que leurs
rapports devient devient complètement
débalancé vous avez des gens qui
décident de modérée des contenus et
c'est arrivé et on recommence on l'était
venir m'en que des contenus dits modérés
qui étaient des contenus tout à fait
correct parce que les fameux modérateur
en thaïlande par tous était confiné en
raison de lakovic 19
or si on engage des modérateurs lundi
dont nous ne sommes pas une campagne
média nous sommes une compagnie de
technologie mais les contenus qui
circulent sont des contenus de médias et
facebook permet par exemple à brisbane
news qui se fait un malin plaisir à voir
une section qu'on dit plus embrouillé au
des nouvelles qui sont complètement
fabriquée très souvent d'être un média
officiel sur cette plateforme hulot est
d'utiliser toutes les techniques
publicitaires toutes les tactiques de
construction de diam's que permet la
plate forme et c'est ce que des gens
comme monsieur trempe recherche à l'aide
l'élection 2016 quand on compare ce
qu'hillary clinton investit versus
monsieur tram on ne faut pas que quelque
chose qu'à marcher là dessus c'est
presque du double et même plus entre
autres quoi tout le monde se fait un peu
de publicité de capital politique
lettres sur wii nadia seraiocco merci
pour cette analyse ce soit ça m'a fait
plaisir gérad merci à vous